welcome the fat man hi Batman I'm Kevin
Smith okay the first thing running
through your head is my lord he looks
tan and he looks good he looks a little
too good man that's right I got magic
hair and makeup all over my face because
we were doing poster shoot for comic
book men season six returning very soon
to AMC right after geeking out which
starts on AMC August 14th and Sunday
nights after fear The Walking Dead
me and Greg Grunberg doing the show we
sit around suck the dick about
everything that we love in the world
that's not real not real people if you
turn it in to watch two bears sucking
dick that ain't the show for you you
want to see two Bears appreciating
movies like going off on Suicide Squad
stuff like that geeking out the show for
you we're not here to talk about either
those shows we're here to talk about the
aforementioned very briefly Suicide
Squad that's right the DC Universe stars
should my two DC Universe
or as they're calling it the DC extended
universe I don't know why they're not
just called a DC movie UDC mu DC mu or
filmic or cinematic DC see you maybe
that's why they're not doing a DC see
you so maybe it's just DC you regardless
we're often full-swing it just now retro
actively begins with a Man of Steel as
we've seen has moved forward with Batman
V Superman as we saw earlier this summer
or before the summer began [ __ ]
Springs I don't long ago it was all I
know is right after Deadpool and so that
kind of hurt but now third installment
has happened I held up four fingers and
said three three movies have happened
the third one is Suicide Squad and they
got David Ayer to direct it now I'm a
David Ayer fan and he's not a huge
filmography but I like the stuff the
guy's done he wrote training day which
is movie everybody loves Antoine Fuqua
director
but I don't know his office strength of
that or not he got this movie and a
watch which is like cop movie and stuff
and you know the Penicillium of those
but man oh man was this insanely good
like this dude air is true filmmaker
Manny
you watch that movie he uses every media
you can in telling a visually oriented
story uses dashboard cams in the cop car
uses body cams not just the standard 35
millimeter probably digital at that
point cameras to cover the action
there's brilliantly shot very gripping
performance driven movie wonderful stuff
next flick he did I couldn't care less
about they were like Brad Pitt's an
attack movie has a [ __ ] tank movie
I'm give a [ __ ]
World War two I've seen it enough man
unless Captain America one woman's there
I want to see World War two anymore but
somebody said people a lot of people I
trust like year after came out though
you should watch that [ __ ] tank movie
to that tank movies really good
finally Lera from enough people I was
like talking I'll watch the tank and the
tank movie was dope man like he made a
tank movie [ __ ] good so right away
I'm like I'm watching this guy anything
he does I want to see they announced
he's doing Suicide Squad so right away
I'm like what is it dude like this
because he works in the gritty and the
real and stuff what does that dude going
to do Suicide Squad what a great pairing
man of everything he could chose he
chose that enter into the DC Universe
and these characters very unreal and
they announced there's going to be
Harley Quinn Suicide Squad so we got
even more excited but I was exciting
I'll everyone in the world who likes DC
Comics was excited because finally man
we're going to see some other characters
not Batman [ __ ] Superman over and
over again they just gave us wonder one
finally now they're giving us a [ __ ]
plethora of characters including
Deadshot Harley Quinn Killer Croc
Slipknot briefly uh let me stick
spoilers uh who else the Enchantress
katana Diablo man I think I got
everybody let's goes and of course the
Joker the return of a cinematic Joker
the first time we're seeing a Joker
since Heath Ledger's so brilliantly
portrayed the Joker in the Dark Knight
so it's tall order this movie's got a
lot going on we also heard whispers and
then we saw in the trailers that like
Batman was going to be in it [ __ ] him
before the trailers man they're shooting
outside Toronto people like [ __ ] up
Batman's on the roof of a car Ben
Affleck's on the roof of guard it wasn't
really brave stuntman it was on
that carpet Batman was indeed in the
movie we had that told to us early on we
saw proof and stuff so there was high
expectations for this movie across the
board
I got a kid who's named Harley Quinn and
this movie was her religion the moment
they start dropped that first trailer
she would cry and watch it let everyone
eat my kid cries a lot of people liked
it better stop crying at least she ain't
cracks I'm like shut up she crying cuz
she's like Harley Quinn so shut the [ __ ]
up she crying because she got a Harley
Quinn back she cried because we wanted
to like premiere she loves Harley Quinn
it's her namesake and she loves Margaery
as well who played her so my kid man as
soon as they dropped this first trailer
which was like epic the trailers for
this movie were pieces of art in and of
themselves from what I understand they
might have helped shape the movie a
little bit later on regardless trailers
were fantastic she watched that first
show over and over again man like it was
its own mini movie with amazing
soundtrack her expensive soundtrack that
they had and this movie has that
soundtracks [ __ ] nuts
how much needle drops in this musics
like casino probably the most expensive
soundtrack I ever seen in a movie since
casino it's just like every song you've
ever heard throughout your entire life
that cost money is in this [ __ ] movie
and they move on very quickly I like
that a low bone Studios like mega rein
use any music you want and stuff like
that it's very rare they did in this
instance so the kid was watching this
trailer forever when they open the next
trailer drop the next trail she was all
over that she was all over me about like
you got to get us there you got to get
me and to see this movie early and stuff
I got that much juice I told her and
stuff so we did wind up getting the
tickets to go to the premiere the other
night and she was beside herself she saw
Margot Robbie on the red carpet she
started crying so I was talking to Busby
at the time I pull the kid up onstage
was look at this mess she [ __ ] loves
Margot Robbie so much she cries unreal
so we wanted to see the movie together
her expectations were [ __ ] high I'll
give you her review and she can't do
that she ain't got a dick but she was
just a boob
she loved the [ __ ] movie in a big bad
way for what it's worth there's a
seventeen year old girl who was the star
of a movie comes out September 2nd
called yoga hos resorts and it's on
screens August 30th for a fathom events
like one time only in theaters with a
Q&A afterwards and stuff and then
September 2nd comes out in theatres she
got her own movie coming out
you
[ __ ] like most critics in the world and
most people she can give a [ __ ] about
Kevin Smith booty all she cares about
was suicide squad and she saw and she
was [ __ ] beside herself she's
immediately like any good fan as soon as
it over she's bawling she was like who
was it next one
so there's your review
seventeen-year-old girl this is her
[ __ ] movie man now a review from a 46
year old man a man who likes comic books
management reading this stuff forever
man who's been waving the flag for this
kind of thing since the beginning of his
[ __ ] career when comics weren't cool
man so what did I think about it I
thought it was [ __ ] dope I think he
did a great job
I honestly think like I used to be one
of those cats that was like they should
give comic book material to people that
know comic books very well and stuff
David's movie to me was commercial for
you can give compliment or the people
outside the medium maybe didn't grow up
with the [ __ ] in their blood or whatever
and it creates a real interesting effect
this is gonna I don't want this to sound
dismissive this this movie was like a
hot topics come to life like you were in
the mall and suddenly hot topics came to
life and start fighting in front and
[ __ ] like that
it was dope man it felt young and I'm
like 40 mm in midlife over midlife let's
be honest I'll be dead in five years 46
years old man I felt like a kid watching
this mood not just because oh my god I
love these characters I'm serious and my
favorite characters up on the big screen
and said just felt young have this
energy to it and stuff and I dismissing
the critics and whatnot people some
people have kind of railed against movie
if you don't like it you don't like it
and I'm not saying they don't get it by
any stretch of imagination don't [ __ ]
put my words in a way where suddenly
[ __ ] critics of my [ __ ] again and
[ __ ] or vice versa
but I I you know I could see whereas
maybe this movie might not be for you
know everyone m know movie is but this
movies from the youth man oh my god this
movie felt young and vibrant and stuff
like that while being like dark and
twist and emote Santa felt like
rebellious teenager whole [ __ ] movie
man but one that you want to be around
not one we were like well gonna hate
this kid it just it felt naughty
just a little bit corporate naughty you
know that
it's not that naughty at all but it felt
like you know there's a grit and grime
to it
I enjoyed the hell out of let's go
through the flick if you will starts by
introducing us to Amanda Waller and a
movie by all the day was wonderful but
Amanda Waller's we seen the trailer sets
up the whole like we've got to put
together a task force what if Superman
[ __ ] came to earth and ripped off the
president said whatever [ __ ] we got put
together task force x-man anybody read
the comics knows John Ashe Ashe
strangers amazing book suicide spot
started way back in the late eighties
bummer mcli had Deadshot the original
incarnation had Rick Flagg in the
original incarnation as well so she
wants put together a band of the worst
of the worst this seems like more of the
new 52 incarnation of the Suicide Squad
cause it's got Harley Quinn in it and a
host of others Killer Croc and stuff so
same idea you take it's the Dirty Dozen
with comic book characters with
supervillains been in existence the
comic for over twenty years finally they
get a big-screen retelling so when we
meet the squad to be they do it in like
vignettes of that are very comic book II
in terms of felt like you're turning a
page seeing a splash and then reading a
page back story before turning a comic
book page hitting with another [ __ ]
awesome splash page and then reading the
backstory and stuff like that
of a secret origins book or something so
we meet the flat of the this the whole
squad that way and I think I think that
smelled like Geoff Johns to me I smelled
the very Jeff John somebody who knows a
lot about DC Comics and knows like this
is a way to introduce everybody in a
really clean manner and it goes on it's
not fast it's not just like oh man it
was quick and they introduced everybody
and give backstory the two most
thrilling of course is for Deadshot
played by Will Smith who is fantastic in
this movie anybody it was just like all
Will Smith is in the movie man you've
been doing ensemble piece total ensemble
piece and he's charming is [ __ ] hell
charm Street across the boards I was a
guy who was like man if they hire Will
Smith is gonna wear [ __ ] snot gonna
wear to mass the whole time via whited
mask he's not [ __ ] Deadshot he wears
the mask in movie couple times but I'll
be honest with you as a guy looking for
the [ __ ] mask
I was kind of happy didn't wear the mask
because he was he was enjoying it was
enjoyable to watch maybe was I'm a good
[ __ ] time and stuff like that so
Will Smith wonderful as Deadshot they
introduced Deadshot Floyd Lawton and it
really should lose daughter if you know
those comic books including like the
Deadshot miniseries you know like
something happens with his kid in the
books that they don't do in this movie
but it's got there's some potential
there [ __ ] like that
so in there in his secret origin that
show him you've seen it in some of the
clips online like taking out a dude but
then he's walking with his kid and
[ __ ] Batman gets the drop on him in
an alleyway and stuff and then he gets
the drop on Batman you could kind of
shoot him and the kid stands away she's
like daddy don't do it but it's just so
[ __ ] dope man to see like Batman the
use of Batman in this movie as opposed
every other movie we've ever seen Batman
in which is like Batman the brooding
[ __ ] there the hamlet of comics
and [ __ ] but melancholy bet it's all
about him and whoever he's fight in that
[ __ ] movie so um so you know you're
inundated with Batman if you're Batman
fan that's good but they used him so
sparingly same way they would use him in
a Suicide Squad comic where's like you
know and then he [ __ ] showed up and
then Batman's there and he's in and out
of the story man he's interacting with
some of your favorite characters seeing
him there with Deadshot the scene [ __ ]
I wasn't in the folk costume does the
only thing would have made it [ __ ]
like I would have [ __ ] nut it dude
unassisted that would've been weird cuz
my kid was sitting there but [ __ ]
that would have done it for me man if he
was in the [ __ ] Deadshot here he was
just looking like Floyd Lawton and stuff
but still like there he is dead shot and
[ __ ] Batman and stuff and in an
alleyway and then eventually buy back
here's something you [ __ ] never see
in a Batman movie particularly in that
last Batman movie Batman pulls out a set
of cuffs he's not just like another one
down was brand this corpse and she had
he actually pulls out cops to arrest a
guy that's very sorry comic books to me
I kind of like that so seeing him me
dead jab at me meet Deadshot and [ __ ]
Batman and got to play Deadshot together
in a movie was in the ill-fated Jersey
girl but barely David Ayer was like good
pairing he put those two together you
can get that idea for me I ain't saying
that don't [ __ ] write that I said
that [ __ ] I just think it's ironic the
Batman when Batman met Deadshot it
wasn't in Suicide Squad technically it
was in Jersey girl a movie that Batman
would probably rather forget many of
that next person we meet Harley
when that's the [ __ ] marquee name in
this movie as much as Will Smith is an
absolute star and Deadshot's phenomenal
and the flick Harlequin this is a
character that everyone's been waiting
over 20 years to see pop up on the big
screen we've seen her in the animated
series where she began just seen her in
the books we've seen her in the video
games now finally she's up on the big
screen played by the same lady who was
going out Leonardo DiCaprio in that
[ __ ] Wall Street moving [ __ ] similar
accent whatnot so she was good choice on
the surface you know she kind of looks
the part of Harley Quinn Harleen Quinzel
if you will so you know we've seen her
throughout the trailers and but you know
everyone got over the look I got a look
right away in terms of what Mandy she
ain't wearing the [ __ ] onesie where's
the [ __ ] onesie they show you the ones
in the movie [ __ ] there's a scene with
the [ __ ] ones he's quick clip her
dancing with Joker one point she pulls
the onesie out the box and you see the
Alpha but you saw her in the full full
outfit and I'll be honest with you like
that was something I was like why won't
they [ __ ] why is she dressed like this
and [ __ ] widely I felt like a parent
yelling am i kid why are you dressed in
these booty shorts where is your onesie
and stuff I was really outraged but I'll
be honest with you man like seeing her
in the onesie and the movie for the
brief time she was it's good choice to
put her in the onesie man some [ __ ]
looks amazing on a comic book page and
in real life you're like oh that's what
I've given up [ __ ] family health and
friends for this that looks weird and
really so I'm glad they gave her a
different look you know than the than
the ones he looked but I was [ __ ]
elated that the ones he was on display
the leotard whatever you want to call it
[ __ ] that was dope Margot Robbie is
Harley Quinn and she's just fantastic
they've already announced that there's
going to be a standalone Harley Quinn
movie I look forward to that in a big
bad way man everything they gave us with
the character so far has been fun in
this movie and enjoy both the Joker
stuff the Harley Joker stuffs really got
soft Paul Dini after moving Paul Dini
co-creator of arlequin so something of
an authority and I was like dude the
Joker relationship and he and Paul goes
I almost cried watching the movie
because he actually loves her like is
the version that Paul and Bruce Timm
created for the animated series Joker is
just like the worst abusive boyfriend on
the planet [ __ ] could give a [ __ ] about
Harlequin
need to do something but in in the movie
there's actual like there's this running
love story between the two that's
actually kind of sweet now some people
like if you think the [ __ ] Joker and
Harley can have a sweet relationship
dude that I could shudder to think what
goes on in your marriage I'm talking for
these characters don't base your [ __ ]
life's on and [ __ ] like that but in
terms of doing Joker and Harley Quinn
it's not like you know he does create
her and seduces her and [ __ ]
electrocute sir looks like a 1-point but
she seems kind of game for it she's like
I could take anything and then she makes
the choice that's the other thing they
do the new 52 Harlequin origin where you
know she falls back into the vat of acid
kind of like the Joker but in this one
like there it's you know it's like do
you love me will you doctor me and she's
like she chooses to like throw herself
into the bat and then after she dives in
he [ __ ] swine dies after it's [ __ ]
sweet man like I gotta be honest with
you like I didn't see it coming I
thought they'd do it straight especially
because I saw pieces of Leto all over
the trailer and one shot early in the
first trailer where you heard his laugh
and Harley Combs like uh-oh so you
thought maybe maybe she didn't [ __ ]
go for maybe there used to be dating and
now in this movie they're not but it's
it's insanely sweet man I didn't see
that one coming that aspect of the movie
Leto's Joker I liked a lot and I think
they used him just the right amount I
think if you'd used him a whole movie
like the same length that they use teeth
Ledger's Joker you would sit there and
try to make comparisons but in a way
since they used him sparingly they kind
of use him like Batman in the movie he's
in the movie more than Batman but
Batman's in a couple scenes he's in the
Harley origin the background secret
origin you show they go through her
entire story kind of in clips and then
you know that scene you've seen online
with the Joker and Harley in a car and
Batman Batmobile chases and he jumps on
the roof and [ __ ] and she's like now how
date night she keeps firing through the
roof and then a car goes into the drank
Joker and Harley Quinn and Batman like
you like grappling off the roof and
saves himself but then puts on the
breather and [ __ ] Swan dives in dope
he goes and rescues Harlequin Harlequin
light gets in space and underwater he
punches her in the face which you know
some people like a man is a little harsh
and [ __ ] she has a psychopath these are
fictional characters but that does come
like out of the comics and an animated
series Batman's an equal-opportunity
puncher and it was underwater how arc of
that bunch be but I'll be honest the
theater I was in everybody laughed it
was like a stress release kind of like
aha and it wasn't like yay hitting women
they were like oh my god Batman hit
Harley Quinn in real life and we've seen
that in comics before and we've seen
that in the animated series no bunch of
people on the internet right now gonna
be like quarterly Batman never hit
Harley Quinn the animated series your
piece of [ __ ] your massagers by the way
I'm not cheering [ __ ] beating a woman
Jesus Christ so many discs lingers in
this review I just like seeing a real
live Batman in real life Harley Quinn in
a real life crime fighting situation
that's it Jesus okay so margot robbie
kills it man she wonderful like her and
will smith steal almost every scene
therein as does Amanda Waller and then
the rest of the team is you know Killer
Croc doesn't have a [ __ ] ton to do but
it looks [ __ ] badass and it's a funny
kind of PS with them at the end there is
let's see
I loved katana katana do the soul taker
sword and they talk about like you know
that swords got her husband's soul in
and [ __ ] like that and then one point
they show her talking to the sword and
stuff come on man I'm a big [ __ ]
Batman in the outsiders fan I love that
Batman cartoon they did where they
introduced katana it's kind of a new
Robin so the notion that they added in
this and she's wearing a [ __ ] mask
this is phenomenal you got to understand
like you know I think you see a chasm
online where some people like I don't
like this movie and other people are
willing to you know Pole to shut down
[ __ ] rotten tomatoes because they
love this movie so much whether they've
seen it or not that is everything to do
with like you know if you're a Marvel
fan as I've been for years you can see
all these characters come to life on the
big screen and [ __ ] and doing well you
know DC folks it feels like this is our
time and so you're not necessarily going
like this has to you know [ __ ] be as
good a civil war you're just happy to
see Deadshot in a movie you're just
happy to see Harley Quinn presents in a
movie you're happy to see them building
the universe you know there are play
catch up a little bit in the DC movies
and catch up I mean in terms of Marvel's
had a lot more time to do it and they've
built fantastic movies across the
[ __ ] boards a universe full of great
moves throw a rock and every one of
those movies [ __ ] enjoyable [ __ ] DC
and Warner Brothers figuring their [ __ ]
out still and so far I think this is a
massive step in the right direction this
one more so the Man of Steel and Batman
V Superman and this is not a diss on
Jack Snyder who I dig and I think is
fantastic visual stylists as well but
this one felt like this is their
claiming their crease number one they've
got a concept nobody's done yet the bad
guys is the good guys and step two of
that is they're going to have a first
all-female super movie superhero movie
first with Wonder Woman coming next year
so I feel like between Suicide Squad and
Wonder Woman BAM we'll finally see DC on
firm feet right after that is Justice
League and hopefully the universe keeps
going forever and ever and ever
what other characters Diablo has real
touching backstories kind of sweet and
stuff I wasn't very familiar with that
character so he played very well for me
in the movie Slipknot if you love them
just hold on that love for as long as
you can it's pretty quick and let's see
what else can we talk about I talked
about the Batman usage in and out of the
movie the main plot enchantress lady
played The Enchantress the girl with the
eyebrows and stuff she you know there's
not a [ __ ] ton for her to do should you
moon for a little bit and then she's The
Enchantress for most movie but this
change over scene with Amanda Waller is
badass man where she puts her hand Zhu
mu puts her hand on the desk and all
suddenly enchantress like takes her hand
and then flips and they paying up she
looks like the changers [ __ ] like that
stuff I was directing I never would have
thought of that I just would have been
like you know poof some smoke from the
70s and swap [ __ ] on camera and
[ __ ] and then suddenly the enchantress
be there so this is visually [ __ ]
sumptuous David Ayer knows that [ __ ]
chief a lot of gunplay in this movie man
which you know some people might be like
hey in this day and age he'd be prepared
for that guns ever were bullets flying
everywhere and stuff but nobody really
getting killed by the bad guys
spoilers spoilers count one two three
Amanda Waller
kill some [ __ ] people who aren't but
have been taken by spiritual possession
enchantress and stuff that was that was
weird to me holy crap but generally
speaking you know when they go to war
when the Suicide Squad is in Midway city
that's all abandoned and [ __ ] like that
and they start busting heads the gooey
face you know [ __ ] people The
Enchantress kind of took over you know
in that third act it kind of gets quite
like the Avengers like who are they
fighting
I don't know faceless monsters that
[ __ ] all look the same and we can
kill them without worrying about blood
or getting an hour rating and stuff so
it does fall into that third act that
most superhero movies do in terms of
life this is mass killing of with no
repercussions because these things are
creepy monsters or whatever the [ __ ] but
it don't that don't hurt the movie one
iota man if you're on board for a flick
called Suicide Squad you're probably
going to expect you know dead shots in
the movie guess what it's gonna be a lot
of gunplay instead but we get to see
Harley Quinn wielding batch olds the
mallet one point but Chevy news on
everybody anybody I was waiting for that
but the bats and big big play for Tanna
sword in flight Captain Boomerang I left
him out of the equation man Rick Flagg
as well Captain Boomerang I'm sure it's
on the internet by now but spoilers 1 2
3 in his backstory we get a flash of the
flash like he's robbing something
awesome there's [ __ ] lightning and
they cut to Ezra Miller in the costume
sitting there I couldn't I couldn't hear
what was said to the whole [ __ ] place
of ruff dog so you know you get a nice
little taste of the flash as well of the
man in costume long before the Justice
League comes together next year what
else you know I think I thought the Rick
flagon and June moon thing was actually
kind of sweet and I thought that like we
got her heart in a box Amanda Waller
thing about the enchantress count that
it changes is character I wasn't way
familiar with them so I liked that
character as well but third action kinda
gets a little lost in the mess of
everybody fighting everything and stuff
like that is one of these movies takes
place at night looks badass man there's
a shot you've seen like a lot honestly
by the time you see this move you've
seen a lot of in the trailers the
visuals and stuff but that shot of Will
Smith on top of a car just
lovable um shooting those [ __ ] wrist
guns and [ __ ] you know I know it's again
there's a lot of gunplay in the world
right now and and maybe nobody wants to
be reminded everyone got mad about a
Jason Bourne billboard a couple weeks
ago for he's holding the gun and stuff
like that but and I'm not excusing and
going come on
but you know [ __ ] dead shot fires
bullets I don't know how else to tell
you that like you can't do that moving
let's dude is she shooting those [ __ ]
wrist guns and he does kill bad people
no women no kids he's got a real like
professional kind of thing
professional moving up like profession
so I'm trying to think what else is in
there man um that I can highlight what
did I love what did I squeal about I
think I've hit them all already I'm
telling you one of my favorite things
was like and I want to see this in every
DC movie just like if it's not a Batman
movie just a sprinkling a Batman so
[ __ ] dope he was in the background
sequence for for Deadshot he was in
Harley Quinn's background story and then
we see him like one other time in the
flick but I you know it's the DC
Universe is now building man like think
about it like you know for years Batman
and Superman and now suddenly they're
like oh we'll put Batman in for a little
bit and then you'll be interested in all
these other characters so I liked it
quite a bit man I think his enjoyable
spark I'm going to see it again this
weekend man I enjoyed that much in some
lines I literally miss because the
screening I was in was [ __ ]
thunderous so it's if you if you're a DC
person and you love the Suicide Squad
I'm sure you're ready there they say the
movies going to open [ __ ] over 100
million hundred twenty hundred forty or
whatever so they're they're going to do
fine you know that some people have
wondered like will the criticism hurt
the movie some critics didn't like it I
don't think so I think this this is a
proof movie it's one of those movies
where you know people if you're in for
the Suicide Squad and a lot of us have
been in for [ __ ] year and change now
moment they've been talking about to
drop in that footage and all the agent
come come as a guy who was anticipating
it I was not let down
I had a damn good time a smile on my
face
like the whole time I was watching this
play so bodes well for the future of the
DC Universe as far as a DC movie fan is
concerned so there it is man Suicide
Squad my meeting encapsulated review you
know I'm not doing too much blot stuff
but okay so they got to stop the plot is
a little bit confusing in as much as
they're gonna they put together by
Amanda Waller and by Amanda Waller
putting them together she unleashes the
villains they actually have to go stop
and they have to go rescue her at one
point in Midway City I'll now she got
there but dun dun dun bought me one iota
man I was just happy to see everything
at play all the characters interacting
the action going on you know it's like
it's like honestly in terms of the style
of the movies comic movies we've seen so
far yes of course Marvel is has mastered
the art form but this was and not taking
anything away from Zack I enjoyed Man of
Steel and I enjoyed Batman V Superman
but this felt part of a different whole
if that makes any sense like this felt
new to me like you know the same way
that Deadpool kind of felt new to me
like they were doing something that an
old man like me was like ah that's
interesting and I wasn't put off by it
at all I was into it so it feels like a
young move I would not be surprised if
the movie opens bigger than they're
saying that it's going to open right now
you know it small rat candy man I mean I
know kids I'm going to mall anymore but
like this is the kind of movie that like
you wake up on a Friday morning and go
like I can't wait to get through school
work [ __ ] Church of whatever sure to
those of church on Friday except my
mother I can't wait to get through all
that [ __ ]
just to get to Friday night this is my
gym you know who's gonna go this movie
not just like people who are like I love
[ __ ] Suicide Squad
I love Harlequin floyd lawton is my
[ __ ] boy whatever [ __ ] not just deep
cuts people this is like the kind of
movie that one if my dad was alive he'd
be like let's go see that Suicide Squad
not knowing anything about it so you're
gonna see a lot of mainstream action on
this movie what that makes me happy as a
guy likes these characters very much
because picking people more people in
the world know who [ __ ] Deadpool is
you know that means gonna make more
Deadpool merchandise has been very hard
to find [ __ ] Deadpool merch
guys for the last 25 years but now now
this characters can belong to other
people so you can reference it and [ __ ]
I could say Deadpool and my mom would
I'm sorry
Deadshot Yipes Freudian slip marvel
Freudian slip Deadshot this is what I
meant um Wow hey man come on they're
[ __ ] close and I'd make that same
mistake if there wasn't two movies
Deadshot [ __ ] dead shots in a [ __ ]
movie now this big Deadshot merchandise
everywhere more than there's ever been
there's been a few pieces and stuff but
now that the characters in the
mainstream movies everywhere same with
in with Harley Quinn I had a I got a kid
a named Harley Quinn as we all know I
said I'm not assuming everyone as I
mentioned earlier not because I'm
pregnant should just claiming yet again
that that kid man like I'm gonna [ __ ]
bring the first place uh I don't know I
was bragging I was like I got laid I
have a kid you got one of those grooves
I got laid at least once anyway our
arlequin we named her that because I've
been a big fan of this stuff my whole
life and you know so I was I was
could've gone either way man honestly
like I could have went in and be like
guys [ __ ] up my girl and instead I
came out and I was like thank you David
I saw David right after premier gave him
a big hug kiss him said you doing the
Lord's work man
telling you the style of this he's on to
something I was glad I hope he does
another one I hope he's not put off by
you know [ __ ] some people not diggin
the movie like if I was I wouldn't be in
this business anymore but he should do
this again I told him I have to press it
but I like about your careers you're
like Angley dude everyone in your movies
don't look like the last one you do this
then you jump here you do this jump here
and do that you can't say oh that looks
like a David Ayer movie because your
Styles been so switched up so keep doing
that but that being said I said go back
to this genre because you did something
[ __ ] dope here my butt watching
movies like this mall life I like what
you did I'm like what you're on to bring
more of this so hopefully he does he's
not put off by some people not liking
you know what money saps all-women's
this movie opens huge doesn't really
matter
the day and continues playing huge DC
extended universe is off - I feel great
start with Suicide Squad this to me is
like yes okay yes yes now we're at the
table now we're at the table there it is
man so go out and see it obvious I'm a
big fan you may catch me in the theater
watching it a second time this weekend
and stuff I'll be the guy down front and
hockey jersey going big did it [ __ ] I'm
in the bag full of [ __ ] all right man
for fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith
come back next week tune in same fat
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
YouTube / Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder